this six page paper is the best I ever
wrote if you measure it in order of
ideas per per byte so so if anybody
wants one of those reprints they're
there I've also got here six copies of
the of the em mixed documentation as it
stands up as it stands today there's
only six here but it's downloadable
anybody can you know if you click on the
on the home page now you can get you can
get the post group for it but if people
here are really seriously a promise to
you know to read it closely and and and
report errors to me you know I I have
six here you know I mean if they're gone
Donald I found one one error in it this
afternoon but anyway yeah there is also
one more announcement next Friday a week
from a week from this Friday I'm going
to give another lecture in this room
it's not in the computer amusing series
but it's a different thing it's about
digital typography and they tell me that
my book called digital typography was
was printed last week in Winnipeg at
least the you know the ink went on the
paper last week and and theoretically
the copies will arrive here either next
Thursday or next Friday in time for this
lecture and I plan to show the book at
that time and see it probably for the
first time myself it's a book that
summarizes everything I did about on
attacking meta font and other things
like that
over the last 20 years and and I think
you know it's a lot of fun too I don't
want to see this all in one book okay
that that's the end of my announcements
I'm going to talk today about this thing
if you hear em mix a riff machine for
the new millennium now I guess the first
thing I should show you is this cartoon
which I saw here which says you know the
mayonnaise for the next
millennium chips for the power for the
next millennium the toilet paper for the
next millennium
it says 1999 is going to be a long year
that's probably true but but I think in
this case like MX has has a little bit
of a reasonable claim for this title
because the M stands for millennium I
mean each M&M extends for a thousand and
so on and as as we'll see what like I
got one more graphic here and show you
the happy hour now M I think most of you
probably know that there was a computer
that still is a computer in my books the
art of computer programming called NICs
and I bought the new edition of the art
of computer program here to show you
where where mixes define that because we
can see on page 124 the new got Allison
can use it
that's great wonderful okay so you see
this little construction symbol here
this is part of the of the art of
computer program is still under
construction in fact this M mix
represents the very last hurdle I have
to get out of the way before I can
really grind out volume for at speak now
so it says it must be admitted that mix
is now quite obsolete they were replaced
in the subsequent editions by a new
machine called M mix the 2009 a mix will
be a so-called reduced instruction set
computer wit risk which will do it let
me take on 64-bit words so be even nicer
there makes it will be similar the
machines that become dominant during the
1990s task of converting everything in
this book for mix to M mix will take a
long time volunteers are solicited to
help with that conversion process like
that's one of my main goals today is to
try to see how many of you in the
audience I can convince that you like
that you would love to join this
volunteer effort meanwhile Arthur hopes
that people will be content to live for
a few more years with the old fashioned
mix architecture still worth knowing
because it helps
contact for subsequent development well
this was the old the old machine
mix that it was and it was designed in
1963 and I think you know it it was
still it still looked fairly reasonable
in 1973 and we had we even had a working
a young meeting of the mud the mixed
user group where we all had mugs and
stuff to celebrate in those days and but
in the late seventies you know people
started using reentrant coating more
memories got huger huger and the VAX
came out and and and machine language
just started to look very baroque you
couldn't enjoy programming a mini man
anymore and so anyway but now mix is
totally different from the machines that
are that are out there and and so and so
I knew that that it was becoming more
and more of a sore thumb as time time
went on that's why I doing this now now
I've got the I've got a web page about
about it I suppose a lot of you have
seen the web page because I checked this
afternoon and there were 18,000 hits on
so they so so it tells about you know
something about the background of it and
oh yeah Oh before I forget I have to
show you this about the name excuse me
that talk about this trivial stuff
before I get into the deep stuff cause
help me remember mix was it was the 1009
and the reason was that it was the 1096
- you heard of that
6650 that was mike no 650 was was the
one I learned on 7 or 9 all these
feasting the you three you caught univac
three solid-state 18 all these machines
including the AI which people have
missed misread as the as an 11 that's
actually not a PDP 11 at the
komp2 but anyway you add these numbers
together and you know divided by 16 you
get 1009 what's the average of that so
that so now mixes the world's first
polyunsaturated computer and and when
this book has been translated into many
languages from the translators in Russia
rotini said well how do you translate
polyunsaturated into into Russian I said
it's it's totally anti revisionist ik
are the point is it was some it was some
buzz word that somebody on Madison
Avenue would be able to say no I I don't
know exactly what I'm gonna say about
m-makes here if you've got a good a good
idea for how to replace this then let me
know but but John Hennessy and Dave
Patterson came up with with the second
polyunsaturated computer in their book
on computer architecture and is called
Deluxe DLX and and that's you know 560
and they found DLX was actually you know
560 you could get by this company in
calculation so I had to prove this too
and so the 2009 is here it comes from
crayon IBM 801 risk to Clippers you know
300 AMD 29k Motorola 88 k ib M 601 Intel
a 960 alpha 2164 power to midst 4,000
itachi super h4 strongarm 11 the story
strongarm Han at 10:00 in the sparc64
you add all those numbers together
divided by 14 2009 had to be 2000 now
and there was a dance group at Stanford
a trusted or not not tested or at the
Dinkelspiel a few years ago called monix
and and i but but i actually found out
that that that that ma max mo mm IX is a
is a good is a popular dialect word in
Ozarks and it means to screw something
up I mean so anyway there's a lot of
there's a lot of reasons to have a
computer called moments damaged but but
maybe maybe you should do like tech as
they missed
and now the the the webpage also has it
has it has a defensive why have a
machine language at all and and all you
know you know people don't really probe
spend much time programming in assembler
anymore so why should i why should I
harp on it and I explain all these all
these extremely important reasons why
why it's a why I believe that it's that
in the book in a series of books like
mine it's important to have have some
kind of a of a of a model that's that's
realistic it's positive to base things
on instead of just working from from top
down I like to also work bottom up and
and so I so I discussed the the ideas
here and in fact the high level
languages keep changing but but at the
low level we can have some some some
understanding of what's easy to do on a
machine and what isn't and there there
are quite a there are quite a lot of
reasons and there's somebody I don't
want to go into but I don't want to
spend the time right now let me see what
other handouts do I have here yeah I'll
get you those so but but but basically I
want to I want to have some a machine
language which is actually very very
much like the most machines in some in
some way now what other what other
criteria did I did I want for this foot
for this language you know the this I
should also say that they that the very
first time I ever gave a lecture called
computer musings was was almost exactly
seven years ago and and I talked about a
mix at that time that was my first
computer musing was called M mix a risk
computer for the new millennium and and
and I had just read a few
half a year before that no no a few
months before that Hennessy Patterson's
first edition of their book on on
computer architecture speaking of the
devil and and just a phrase Jonathan and
and and at that time John very
graciously looked at the entire document
that I had about about what I thought MX
would be in 1992 and and and made the
extensive comments and and his main
comment at that time was it's gotta be
64-bit machine at that time my god you
know essentially every computer was I
don't know I had the idea that okay I
had to go down from 36 bits to 32 bits
but I was never going to get any more
and and you know UNIX seemed that the
ins had to be 32 so but but machines
were coming out 64 and he was absolutely
right that and so that that impacted
very heavily on the design so so now now
after the second edition of Hennessy and
Patterson came out my new design is very
heavily influenced by by that I also
want to give a special thanks to dick
sites is he here no okay well maybe
he'll show up in a minute anyway God
dick who's designer of the Opera
worked with me actually on the first mix
when he was a freshman at Stanford he
and I worked on the on a simulator for
the first mix which in 1970 and
published a CS report about that and now
and then now he spent a lot of time with
me this last year with the design of
emic now the so first of all I learned
from from Henderson Patterson's book
that computer that that about RISC
machine stark the concept of reduced
instruction set machines which which
which originated
many places around the world but I think
a lot of credit goes to Stanford and
Berkeley projects that came out of about
1980-81 and and also some independent
projects at IBM in other places and and
the wonderful thing about the RISC
machine is that it's actually it
actually can be nice to read the Machine
language coding this was not true of a
lot of the later ma machine languages
they that that came out but but all of a
sudden hey there was a thing yeah you
know there was a window in time when
complain machine language was it was fun
again and and it'll probably go away you
know as people have to have to have to
you know I don't know these very high
very long instruction word lines and so
on are going to they're going to come
out with languages that are again not
never to be seen by a human being but
but the the the kind that this we're
still at a time when when almost
readable instructions are going on in
the machine and that is that was great
news for me now so anyway I want it to
be realistic now I but I also had to be
sort of I don't know how do you say it
well what is realistic means in some
ways that's to be economical but if I
made it economical for now according to
Andaz law is it would be wrong
very soon because computers are
everything is changing so fast and so I
figured I'd better design this thing so
that it instead of instead of looking
for what I have not now but I better say
what am i what will I do if I can
actually you know make the make the
Machine 10 times who put put 10 times as
much on a chip now or a hundred times as
much on the chip and so on and I so that
this isn't going to look like it's it's
it's too much mired in the past by the
time I actually get to finishing my book
and so I had to
you know a little bit ahead of time in
this design or try to predict big trends
in some way but I but I wanted to I want
it to be something that that that that
could be buildable you know assuming
present trends continue although maybe
we couldn't build it now I don't have a
real realistic expectation that anybody
will actually ever build it because that
cost millions and millions of dollars
for all eight alia but I still wanted to
plant you know I wanted to design one
that I would really like to own and and
and and it wouldn't be great if somebody
would actually build it someday it you
know now they'd have to probably spend a
few more millions of dollars just for
patent rights to some of the ideas I'm
stealing because I because I haven't
paying attention to the things that
makes that is expanded nowadays is
important but anyway I think it didn't
want it I wouldn't feel right if it was
just some only a textbook computer that
couldn't be built and that and I didn't
go into the into all the issues that
that you have to worry about in a real
machine like what happens when the power
fails and what end and how do you
exactly what happens on an interrupt
then and how do you convert virtual
addresses to physical addresses and and
a lot of messy things that that have to
be that have to be and so I studied the
I studied as much as I could about the
machines that are used now and I try to
to take the cleanest aspect of the
things so another thing was I want it to
be clean and nice I didn't want to have
it look like it's designed by a
committee because you know it's assigned
by me and I have a chance to you know I
don't have to satisfy anybody else so I
wanted to have the nicest guy in some
way saying I wanted to be easy to learn
because that's the main purpose of it is
for that I can you know I can just you
know describe it in my books and
somebody can look at it and
and they got the idea pretty fast and
and and you know they don't have to
dwell on it if they're not going to
write that many programs in it just so
that they get the idea in mind of what a
risk machine is like you know I I figure
maybe 1% of the people who who look at
em mix are actually going to write a
program for a mix but but so so I got a
design for the 99% still I want those 1%
to really be happy and and that's the
other thing is fun that is it will be
it'll be a pleasure for people who do
want to spend more time on this machine
to to do it there's a lot of advantages
to a machine independent machine you
know everything is changing so fast in
in computer world these days it's nice
to have a few things that that that last
for a little while and so by having a by
having a machine like this it's
conceivable that that that we'll be able
to do various modeling experience
experiments and so on that'll that'll
they'll still make sense over a period
of time but but I can't afford to change
my books every time my new trend comes
along and I'm already 61 years old and I
got lots to do and and and so and so you
know I'm trying to write about I'm
trying to write about timeless truth
things that are always important you
know so I want to have one machine that
like that will stick stick stay the same
although it is still is adaptable to
many to many different configurations
and so you can have even though it's a
hypothetical mythical machine there are
there are cheap versions of the mythical
hardware and and expensive version of
mythical hardware I'm going to be giving
a talk on Wednesday March 3rd we the
next computer musing where I talk about
they this simulator that I that I'm
building for him makes I'm I I thought
that was heavy into debugging it
yesterday and I got it to interrupt for
the first time on Sunday and this this
this simulator shows how Amex can
existing infinitely many configurations
as to how is to all kinds of
combinations of functional units and
caching and you know and all he
everything every buzzword I've heard of
a you know has it has a way to
describing
endemics well so I don't know I might
think of other other other parts of the
design but but in general I wanted it to
be combination of all these all these
things and I and I came up with this
stuff with this design that I want to
show you today now the the the first
thing is simplicity I this was this was
the same as I had in 1992 every
instruction is has has four bytes to it
in the operation code XY and Z and the
operation code so there's 256 operation
codes 256x256 YC succeeds and typical
instruction might be this one 32 1 2 3
which means 32 means add and it says set
register 1 equal to register 2 plus
register 3 so this is this is typical of
a of a RISC machine to have to have it
like this kind of a three three
registers mentioned in an instruction
one register that is is the second
register operated on with the third
register now the thing that's that's
pretty that's that's really different
however is that there's 256 registers
that makes it however you know as I said
ahead of time because you know we got to
figure out something to do with the
larger chips but also easy to learn
because because here you are you know
all these bytes are are very simple in
fact I believe that that having a lot of
registers is is is extremely good for
compact for compact probing
programming because a lot of a lot of my
programs great deal of the stuff will
live in registers all the time and never
appear in memory and this makes this
this saves a lot of space when you're
trying to to refer to the it to the
numbers that you're working with so it
so having a lot of registers has has a
lot of advantages now it has
disadvantages too because if you want
one of there
one of the disadvantages is that when
you when you're swapping from one job to
another you have to save the state of
the of the computation and so what if
the job isn't actually using very many
registers you don't want to have to
store 256 bit registers into memory and
and then load them again when you when
you come back well I've taken care of
that too is we'll see let's see the app
I said there's 256 ups and this is up
and so now let me show you this this
chart here which is which is near the
end of my reports like I have an extra
copy of it I'll just put it over I'll
just put it here
um this these are the can you zoom back
a little bit you know these are the 256
codes that that exist like I guess I
kind of like to have a t-shirt that has
this on it because because anyway these
are the these are the so you see that
that in in hexadecimal is 0 0 through FF
and I I won't go through all of them
with you this afternoon but I'll give
you the idea they fall although there's
356 that's a that's a lot if you ever
have to try to to address 256 Christmas
cards you'll know what I mean but but
they fall into about a dozen easily
remembered categories in the patterns
and and and what one of the things that
I want to stress is there is there's a
cleanliness of the designer the sort of
the orthogonality of the design that the
things that are that are true about one
instruction are generally true of all
instructions so for example in this in
this format that the instructions
usually have this form
form where the where the x and y and z
are independent but sometimes y&z are
tied together and so you have you know a
16-bit something-or-other
and sometimes all XYZ are tied together
as one 24-bit field so you have you have
essentially three formats of
instructions where where all the bytes
are independent or where y&z are tied
together or XYZ are tied together
another thing is a lot of these
instructions if ok outs and you can zoom
in you can zoom up again now
maybe your name wasn't Allison I
forgotten whoever you are on TV can you
zoom up yeah now for example the very
first instruction is 0 0 is called trap
and this is a in generally sort of an
extensive it's a it's a forest
interrupted means I I know I want to
call the operating system I know I
wanted to to stop on this and here you
could you can make that to any extent
any the operon system to do any
instructions at once on that the very
last one all ones is is trip which is
which is different this is an interrupt
to but it's say it but it doesn't go to
the operating system it goes to you and
and and user programs can write their
own handlers for for trips while the
operating system writes the handler for
the trap so every program has its own
interrupt but don't let the operating
system know which could be used so for
example for breakpoint debugging racing
now and I and usually if something's
wrong with the hardware you get it you
get either all zeros or all ones and so
and so one of these things will happen
and you'll know about it please
now I told you about the add instruction
which adds say you know register why the
register Z and puts it in register X
there's also an immediate and that's
what this bracketed I means in all these
things and and and you see essentially
every instruction that composite that
makes sense to have an immediate
which means is that the 256 almost gets
divided into into into and-a-half 128
because you have adding add immediate
where add immediate says instead of take
instead of taking register Z the
interchange the opcode from 32 to 33
then it would say take register 2 + 3 +
and start and register 1 okay so that's
the idea of an immediate description and
all the immediate instructions take this
this is the this Z field and treat it as
an unsigned constant and and it works
like that
so just by learning the rules of
immediate you learn a whole bunch of
more on how the the add instruction has
both signed and unsigned variants so so
add and add immediate then this of
course subtract asleep is for
subtraction there is a reverse
subtraction net well it's not really it
negation is like you can you can say
calculate 0 minus R Z and and so anyway
those are ordinary instructions on
arithmetic on on 64-bit numbers but then
there's also the something that you sort
of hide under the table unless you
unless you start working with with the
details of machines and that is what
happens if this if you add two numbers
together and you get something that's
too big it doesn't fit in 64 bits
well overflow occurs and so then you
have to decide what are you going to do
about overflow you can ignore it you're
going to make it possible to see it
somehow and what what do you do oh well
now overflow is is a especially
important not only for integer results
but also for floating-point results and
these these instructions near the top
here are floating-point instructions
like fadd floating add and and the and
it was important
to be consistent with the with the I
Triple E standard on floating-point
which is which is well-defined and has
been in existence for more than ten
years and and as a lot as has a heck of
a lot of good ideas in it so so I knew
from the Frog that I was going to use I
Triple E floating point arithmetic in a
mix and and and therefore in order to
keep this whole thing easy to learn and
and clean and so on I had to make what
the rule whatever rules I chose for a
fixed point would have to be the same as
the rules of a floating point and so I
Triple E defines different kinds of
exceptions that can that can occur on
floating point arithmetic the you know
overflow can occur under flow can occur
you can divide by zero you can have a
result that's that's not a number that
you can have a result that's undefined
like square root of a negative number
you can have a you can have a result
that's in exact so they defined a whole
bunch of exceptional conditions and so
and some whatever I did with floating
point numbers I would also do for in for
the the idea of an integer
except integer overflow and so that is
let me show you now something that
there's a there's a web page that shows
these op codes that you that's reachable
from the other end mixed page it says
luton click here for the 206 tacos and
you know that's a shark there and then
at the bottom of that page it tells you
about all other kinds of weird codes in
it and for example the exception codes
that we have are all listed here now the
trip calls the DV v io u v x so in
integer divide check integer overflow
and then the fixed fixed point operation
stuff floating overflow and so on are
these others that come from I Triple E
and I didn't W is a separate I didn't
know I didn't specify what I mean when
you're converting a floating point
number to a fixed point number should it
be an integer overflow that you get our
floating point over
to get I decided to make a separate one
for that so that if you were interested
in calling it one way you could enable
both of these otherwise you do the other
one so I have eight and besides I needed
eight eight codes to fill a byte so so
if it all all packed real nice the so
that's what happens if your add two
numbers together and or subtract one and
the result is out of range
you get into your overflow and then the
then it depends on on what the
programmer wants just as in as in
floating-point so there's a separate
register which says do you want to do
anything special do you want to do you
want to interrupt your program on an
integer overflow or do you just wanna
sort of log the fact that it happened in
ghulam and and that's that panel the
same way as with floating-point so so
actually this if you do decide on
interrupt that you're interested in it
it'll go to one of your own routines
like a trip like that you let you write
yourself that you can write yourself and
you can not you can in this in this
handler you it set up so that not only
can you can you say oh by the way inner
you know you just had an interview just
had an overflow on your instruction set
massage you can also correct it can also
correct the air and substitute another
result if it want to see if he wants to
do something now so these multiplication
and division are are in here somewhere
here's modification I put them up here
because the they tend to be slow
instructions like maybe we combine the
multiplier with a floating point
multiplier in hardware you could share a
lot of the stuff but multiply and divide
again they all that they can make an
overflow and they these instructions are
all 64-bit to 64-bit now however there's
also unsigned arithmetic which which
never overflows never has exceptions and
that's and so you add the add the letter
you
so add an add unsigned says you know
we're doing like in the three language
if we have on unsigned numbers we just
work mod to 264 we just let carries go
in and out the door whatever at the left
end and and so we got we got a lot you
know a lot of unsigned things where it
says you know I don't care if it
overflows here and don't ever interrupt
on these on these guys there's also
negative negative sign and now then
multiply and divide our unsigned are
also are also nicer from the standpoint
of doing what if you're doing multiple
precision arithmetic because of them
unsigned multiply gives you 128-bit
product instead of just 64-bit if you
want to look at the high order bits and
and divide unsigned takes 128-bit in and
produces and produces a quotient and
remainder while the ordinary divided by
does produce remainder but it doesn't
but it was it only starts with a 64-bit
that you've given but they in general
that that's the idea now we got also I
got a whole bunch of little thing like
like to add unsigned it says x 2 and x 4
and add x 8 x 16 in there this is useful
if you if you are have to have to do sub
scripting and you know you want to move
move along by by 2 bytes 4 bytes 8
fights and 16 bytes and now I got to
talk about about multiplied words this
is a little bit fun the we have bytes
here in 8 bits equals 1 byte and
actually let's go let me let me let me
change that because I'm we had actually
two two nibbles is one byte
would because a lot of times people need
a leader word for her like a hexadecimal
digit something that's four bits left
before bits long and it becomes one
nibble and and then of course we we have
then the problem of making other names
here and and I I got a letter with a
good suggestion from a guy who said two
bits is one nip and too big to nips is
one nibble okay now now there's a big
need for a 16-bit quantity the and a lot
of people have come up with different
names for 16-bit things so and they were
but unfortunately that there was there
was the the most common thing for 16-bit
quality is is a word and this is what
this I found even used in in Intel
considered 16-bit to be one word and
even though they go to even the output
of talking about 16 bits as a as a word
and a 64 bit thing with a quad word to
the offer to the to the output to the
people at there on the other hand when
you grow up in the UNIX world everyone
knows that a word is 32 bits and it but
for Cray it word was 64 64 bits and and
so it was quite clear that that word
word had you know impossible to to use
in the way like that that you could get
any agreement on whatsoever and there
were there were a few other proposals
for for 16-bit things and I summarized
all of them actually on a web page if
you're interested and I can refer to if
you look at my news 98 page at the
script discusses it but anyway after
thinking about it and talking over with
a lot of people I came up with the right
answer which is which has been spreading
around the world very rapidly two bytes
is one wide
now it sounds a little bit like word
just say with a Brooklyn accent so if
you know okay
but the rebut it wants to very much to
be a one syllable word that starts with
W and one of the one of the big reasons
for this is that that the extended UNIX
now all the functions that use these
16-bit characters you know Unicode is
growing fast and and it says code that
handles all the essentially all the
world's languages except Burmese and
because they have been able get into
blooming it but but it'll handle Burma
to and and so Unicode the 16-bit code
they is you know the all kind of
subroutines are needed for for things
like like W printf you know and and W
get s and so on all the units are like
all the UNIX the C standard library
functions that that work on 8-bit
characters the corresponding ones for
sixty characters have a W in them and so
so it really is night if this is the
wide pretty wide printed version of the
things going so for two by two the wide
and I've been using this mouthful for
quite a few months and in fact not only
is it's been spreading so fast at that
byte magazine ceased publication last
year and the successor to bite is act
has been named wide and it's going to be
an online magazine is going through
right now but I mean I I did find that
some conflicts like there's also was
already a magazine called Canada wide
for for large Canadians but but you know
that's today you know they aren't
probably you know get a kick out of this
know now so 16-bit things we call them
wise and it works Nick the next thing
though what should I call the the 32-bit
and 64-bit thing and and and and at this
point all these it our memory is good at
remembering a few small things but after
that I have to think about a long time I
I realized that that this kind of clever
use of Y and stuff is not going to it
shouldn't shouldn't continue on because
because it gets to be a difficult thing
of memory after this point so in so out
here I call it a tetra bite or a tetra
you can say tetra bite if it sounds
better to have another syllable in the
word and to Tetris is an octa our octa
bite and it's because because the more
you look at programming these things you
have to somehow have a have a strong
remembrance that for that for associated
with tetra with 32-bit words and eight
is associated with 64-bit words because
you have to realize that you're passing
over that many bytes in the code and
when you whenever whenever you're
looking at a program in and you have to
stop and and think well now how many
bytes is that then that's waste of time
but if it's an octave like you know how
many bytes is so anyway this is the
these are the these are the terms that
that MMX users and I and I believe
they're spreading one so now now I yeah
I kind of like why because you could
yeah you could maybe maybe do I think I
think it was that was already there was
already cuffed by somebody in the I mean
like like I was thinking of octet for
example but octet was was out because
octet is used by all the coding the
information there you commune and I
think I saw it so okay but so anyway the
instructions in in MX here are load byte
or load byte unsigned a load wide load
tetra load octa okay and that means that
you're taking out of memory either one
by two bytes four bytes or eight bytes
and a load byte will also extend the
sign so it so you look at a byte is
considered to be a number between minus
Plus on 27 and and load byte is you know
then then brings the bite into a 64-bit
register now I should mention that that
people say it's a risk it's a reduced
instruction set machine but how can a
machine with 256 opcodes we consider the
reduced instruction set machine and the
reason is that in fact if you look at
the path you know the Alpha and the
PowerPC and stuff like that and count on
out of instruction it's not 56 isn't out
of line in fact the idea of reduced
instruction set is not that there's a
small number of instructions r12 opcodes
but it's a small number of different
conventions in the opcode and really
what they really the characteristic of
the architecture is that the references
to memory are confined to loading and
storing for memory and they and and
everything else is between registers as
a right so it's sometimes called a load
store architecture or a register
register architecture because because
they actually all the instructions in in
the eights nines a and B here in these
four bands are our load store to memory
while the other instructions in the
other and all the other bands are just
between registers and that's the idea of
a RISC architecture now so so in that
case the instruction is not that
register X is set to a function of
register y&z with an ordinary operation
but in this case it means you add
register y de Reyes through Z and then
look in that memory location and then
you either you either load that into
register extra storage directly into
that into that location so so or else if
Z is an immediate then you add this in
this constant to the base register
that's in register Y so that's the idea
of loading mode load byte load byte
unsigned would be the same as loading a
bike but you but you don't sign extend
it you just put in all input zeros into
the into the other bytes load Tetra
unsigned you know loads to the lower -
lower 32 bits but they put upper 32 bits
goes to zero load wide unsigned
now I have a load octa byte unsigned
it's exactly the same as the load octa
byte but that I said I wanted this to
this design to be orthogonal and
consistent so if you're if you're
dealing with something that you know you
the I have a there's something about
this here foolish consistency is the
hobgoblin of okay now yeah no no there
anyway there's reason to be consistent
in design instead of you know I I had
this extra I could have defined some
some fancy opcode in here but it but it
broke the pattern I didn't want to do
that
there there's load a short flow if this
is a floating-point thing because of the
main thing I just if I know when you
have a 64-bit machine single-precision
floating-point the 32-bit floating-point
numbers don't make any sense anymore
it's almost it it's almost terrible to
imagine computing with 32 bit floating
points you have a 64-bit register
except that you might want to pack the
data or get it from some from some you
know some some program that was that was
for but but so it so I can find
them so I don't have a single precision
floating point addition but I can load
it into a register and I can add and I
can store it out again and that's enough
to actually round to exactly the I
Triple E standard but but I don't want
to load high tetra is is that you take
you take a tetra bike but you put it in
the upper half instead of the lower half
and these other instructions are kind of
weird I'll go in come so so then all the
load instructions have a corresponding
store instructions that go with and
store byte store byte unsigned so store
wide wide unsigned tetras and so on
short float high tetra and convention is
that actually a an overflow can occur
when you're storing if you try to store
a bite
and and and the value of the register is
not between minus 128 and +1 or 27 then
over pfenninger also always is signaled
but store byte unsigned just takes the
bite and forgets about it overflows
store a constant is another one in here
you know you can say that you can set
memory to the location to zero or some
small number instead of putting it in
the register okay so the load and store
instructions are our characteristic of
Lists machines that in that that's the
way memory gets in and out of registers
but that's a major major operation and
it made it part of the hardware because
we thought there's all kind of layers of
caches between the memory on the
registers in order to get efficiency now
I'll go quickly through some of the
other stuff here's these these commands
here there's four set commands set high
set medium high medium low and set low
and and these instructions all take a
wide and 16 you know a 16 bit immediate
value so it's a wide immediate and and
puts it into inputs it in theater the
highest wide of the register at the
medium high or the medium low or the low
and you can increment the highest wider
than the medium high wide or into the
highest of the medium highest and not
this means that takeaway bits from so
here we have 16 bit immediate things and
with 4 of these instructions you can
build any 16 bit any 64 bit constant you
want into a register and it takes 4
instructions which is twice 64 bits
because each instruction is 32 bit well
we got we got through those instructions
now the branch instructions are are here
and there's eight of them branch
negative branch zero branch positive
branch odd and then the opposite
non-negative nonzero non positive and
evil and then there's two versions of a
branch and then these branches are
relative to the location so if you say
branch negative two of self plus four
that means you go ahead for instructions
in the code but if you want to go self
minus 4 that's that's the backward
version of the instruction and in that
case you it's like having an extra bit
in the Opera in the opcode because then
you give the the compliment that you
really would say yeah but if you want to
go to self minus 4 you would say branch
negative backward
well the assembler does this for you but
you so you just say branch negative self
-4 was a symbolic name of that location
but but in hardware branch negative
backward wouldn't would say then minus 4
is given in in in two's complement form
so so those are the eight branch
instructions they're easy yeah you just
say you give it the name of of a
register and then if that register is
negative you can branch forward or
backward by the other 16 bits in the
instruction so that gives you a range of
plus or minus 65 cave instructions then
there's the probable branch negative 4
and so on so these are the same as
branch except you give a hint saying I
think I'll probably branch
well the branch says I think I probably
won't branch and then the hardware can
use branch prediction mechanisms to
refine you this this guess but uses this
as the initial guess anyway - the first
time you come to an instruction you can
avoid branching altogether with these CS
and GS instructions that per here this
is conditional set if negative
conditional set of 0 or 0 or set if
negative these instructions the meaning
of conditional set negative is it's this
and says if register Y is negative then
set register X to register Z otherwise
don't say anything
and so you can often avoid a branch
instruction it's much faster on on
modern machine side to to do these
things and the zero said is similar it
says if register Y is negative then set
a register X to register Z otherwise
that register extra zero which turns out
to be even easier to implement and the
personal in lots and lots of program ok
the boolean operations are real simple
the or and or or with negative and with
the negative or compliment or not
then there's nor and man which is the
complement of a our exclusive or and and
not exclusive or so these are 64-bit
operations on bits I should talk a
little bit about the shifts here this is
shift left shift left an unsigned shift
right shift right unsigned one thing I'm
a little bit worried about it might if
my books I have all these instructions
I'm trying to define in such a way that
they that they should have been defined
at all on all the machines now but I
find that almost all machines defined
shift wrong that they for example on a
32-bit machine it'll it'll only look at
five bits of the amount of shift and
it'll it so it won't distinguish between
shifting by zero and shifting by 32
which are rather dramatically different
and in fact and so compilers have to
have to worry and have have you know
have to test for this special case if
they're going to implement the language
over the variable variable lengths shift
so in in in mining up machine is shift
left is exactly equivalent to
multiplying by a power of two including
whether or not an overflow occurs you
know if you want if you if you want to
replace x 16 with a shift left for it's
absolutely legitimate dynamics what but
it isn't on the machine so I'm afraid
maybe we as my books are going to going
to program in the real world are going
to car gonna assume that the real world
is actually as nice as this I don't know
that I but still I'm going to do it the
right way in hopes that you know
machines will eventually change over and
this will be they'll be in the majority
shift left unsigned is this is a famous
shift left but no overflowed occurring
so it's the same as multiplying by
sixteen unsigned shift right again is
equivalent to dividing by a power of two
in all cases and and with the sign
extended in the arithmetic shift
unsigned shift brings in zeros from the
lip so these instructions are really
easy to understand I got a MUX
instruction here this is multiplex
instruction which which says register X
is set to either register Y are ready
for Z and each bit position is
determined by a mask which is in it
which is in another ago a register well
there so you have that fancy that that
fancy instruction there let's see let to
make comparisons you have less than less
than on sign equal equal on sign equal
on sign the same as equal but you
compare where this one register to
another and then you know I said it's a
0 or 1 to pay based on whether the thing
is is is less so so anyways a lot of
these instructions are easy the jump
instruction is trivial that's an
absolute jump here we have a it's
relative with the with XYZ all treated
as a 24 bit constant so you can jump
plus or minus 2 to the 24th instructions
the jump is the same but it's it's
dynamic is for like a case statement in
in in see where you go where you want
this statement in C and I and a get
address is is saying put into a register
the address relative to your present
location so this saves you a lot this
means that air makes programs can pretty
much be loaded into any part of memory
without load or having to relocate a
bunch of stuff well the the families of
instruction have talked about that I've
got arithmetic and we
bullying that load and store we had we
had branching and and I haven't talked
about floating point that that actually
takes it takes a while so I just say
quickly it's it's quite analogous to
everything else we've been saying I have
comparison instruction floating point
less than floating point unordered with
respect to they said these are things
that you need for the I Triple E
standard convert from float from fixed
white the floating point converts from
floating point the fixed point all these
things are are fairly fairly
straightforward and I but I want to talk
about the some of the other more
interesting parts of the machine so yeah
there are there are two innovations I
want to talk about one very briefly and
the other one and a little bit more
slightly more length
the one I want to talk about very
briefly is the is the the instruction
called more and there's M XOR as well
now this is an instruction that doesn't
exist in any in any computer right now
so why should I put it in the machine if
it's supposed to be realistic and so on
well it's because it's ahead of time in
fact I think there was a machine
something like this in the in the micro
unity machine that never saw the light
of day but the but in fact these
instructions are much simpler and
cleaner than then instructions that are
going into a lot of machines now to do
what they called multimedia or
operations or anyway there's a lot of
special hardware going in to facilitate
operations on pixels and stuff like that
and and I have also instructions called
bike jiff and wide gift which which work
on on parts of words simultaneously so
for example you can be sick you can be
subtracting all the part or all the
bytes of
of two different registers but each byte
independently without carrying into the
next and replace it by zero if the
result is negative and these
instructions have actually become known
in Intel world as MMX technology I I can
claim having the word M mix before they
had MMX technology because I gave this
lecture in 1992 but but anyway it's it's
just a interesting coincidence that they
that their MMX technology is for
instructions like this despite different
why I didn't think but the more
instruction is is based on the fact that
64 is actually 8 times 8 and and when
you have a 64-bit word its natural to
actually think of that word as if it was
a matrix of eight rows and eight column
of it and then you can say well you know
sometimes a 64-bit word represents a an
integer
sometimes it represents a floating-point
number but here it also can represent a
matrix and so the and so these are this
means multiple multiply matrices
multiplied the registers together as if
they were as if they were 8x8 matrices
and this end and and M XOR is the same
multiply there's two ways to calculate
the the product of 8x8 boom your
matrices one is by taking the or and one
is by taking exclusive or of the other
things as you're going and and let me
just explain for example if you multiply
by the identity matrix
well you don't change anything but if
you multiplied by the value matrix that
looks like this
you flip the bytes from left to right so
you go big endian to little endian okay
if you if you multiply by this matrix on
both left and right and flip all of its
no but in general you can multiply about
any permutation matrix and you can and
if you multiply by the permutation
matrix on the left your permuting the
bytes of the word if you're multiplying
by that permutation matrix on the right
your permuting the bits within a byte
and if you have several ones in a row
then you you then your boot you're
putting several but you're putting
several bites together so so I giving
the right up I give a whole bunch of
applications of this to show how you can
do lots of lots of stuff with disappear
instructions and a lot anime and it
combines nicely with the other things
like the confidence instruction so so
and dick sites told me that every every
computer architect is entitled have at
least one instruction that's going to
look silly in ten years and so and so
maybe this will be it you know but I
think I think it actually is gonna catch
on with who know it you couldn't use it
in in you know you see compiler would
never use it unless unless you build
them something they were first could
define a data type to be an 8x8 bit
matrix but you can use these things also
for for efficient calculation in finite
field it's it's I don't know I couldn't
resist putting in it now the other thing
I want to tell you about is the stack is
a subroutine linkage in the in the
Michigan subroutine calls a stack or a
register stack now now this is this if
you look at what actually happens in in
in the programs that are being being run
all the time now a significant amount of
time is being spent putting are taking
arguments getting it arguments into
subroutines and getting answering
browsers into subroutines and so on and
passing the results back out of the
subroutine and and so people realize
this and they they design different
architectures in order to in order to
make the the passing of arguments and so
on reasonably fast and and and it has to
work who recursive subroutines and all
kinds of stuff
and the the
well there are various solutions for
this and the one that that came out of
berkeley risc the was now on the spark
is the idea of red of Windows this has
nothing to do with Microsoft this is a
this is but this is a in a separate bank
of registers that you move around as
when you go into a subroutine and you
get to look at the some registers in
common between caller and colleague and
then the other case is where you where
you you pass with the arguments in
registers and with other cool other
convention now each of these has its
champions and it has its pluses and
minuses but but I I have something that
I think is a nice compromise you know it
sort of it sort of doesn't you can do it
either way depending on your on your own
preference and and and and it's no it's
too it's too difficult to explain real
quick but I so also I have to just give
you the highlights but here's the here's
the idea they said I had 256 registers
and that's but but I divided them into
local and global so here so let's
consider this is all these are all the
registers here and I have a I have a
point of G says everything greater than
equal to G is global so G is the max of
G is 255 so that would say you always
have at least one global these registers
are global then I have another register
L that says everything less than L is
local and everything between L and G is
zero now so so one of the what wanted
this this least Tyson was something I
said before that if you're storing the
context of a program you don't have to
store all 256 registers you only have to
store the locals and the global so not
all the zeros in between so if somebody
isn't using these okay but if if
somebody says add
and one of the registers that you're
adding is is in this in this marginal
region between LNG here it just reads
that means as if it's zero if you try to
store into this register then it moves
then L silently moves it moves up you
don't have to know what L is it'll just
you know the idea is the programmer
should use the small numbered registers
whenever possible but if you have an
instruction and the instruction says you
know add dad register 100 to register
200 and put it in in register
20 well register 100 and 200 they might
be local or global depending on the
value of G and the but but but I have to
tell you something else that's different
about local and global otherwise this
concept wouldn't make that much much
sense and then and so the the other part
of the idea is that in fact these local
registers aren't sitting in a linear
array like this what the but actually
the local registers are sitting in us in
a circle that that has an arbitrary
offset and register 0 through register L
are actually sitting somewhere in this
circle when I go into a subroutine I can
I can push I have an instruction called
push goal which which says push down a
certain number of your registers and
going to the subroutine so so so so if I
push them down it essentially says that
the offset is it is here and L has just
decreased by that much so if I say push
go by 10 L has just gotten 10 less and I
push down 10 of my local register now
the subroutine can start using its own
localizer adding to this if it wants to
but it's got all these arguments that
are still in there that are passed it
can put its answers in here and then it
can say pop and it can say pop 5 which
means leave 5 of my local registers and
then go back and take all the ones that
you push when you when you went into me
so so that's the now now the idea is
that you that even though I said push 10
the machine only had to change this
offset and and as you as you issue the
instructions
you have you add the offset to the local
registers but not to the global
registers and you get the local issues
out of this ring while the goal erasers
come out of this out of another out of
another array and so if you're
interested in in the detail so it's all
described in this in this document
that's on the web but the but the basic
idea is something like this if you say
if you like the the sparkle like Windows
then you would say push go eight and pop
eight when you when you're more or less
what you do subroutine language if you
like the nips type of thing you would
say push go infinity in pop zero which
infinity really means push go all of
your locals and pop and and and and and
remove them all on pop enos more or less
that's the same and in Hevesi of a
certain number of global place works for
communication but but the the idea here
is that you you know this this this this
scheme adapts itself to whatever the
needs are if you have a subroutine that
once that wants lots of locals okay it's
got them if not if you have a java
application it wants lots of Global's
you can you can have a slow small value
of G if you have application with lots
of locals you think you can you can let
it grow this way and that's the that's
the idea that I that that late binding
not not to not the architect design in
advance so what's going to be right for
all programs but let the program so know
I had to implement my simulator to make
sure that this idea would work that it
would that you could do it with a
pipeline and not lose too much and of
course there is extra hardware involved
in adding this adding this offset in
here and and keeping track or also
automatically of when you have to store
things and memories that you start
wrapping around the circle you have to
dump things out into memory and load
them back in again
but I've got that all worked out and I
think it's the heart amount of hardware
is reasonable considering the trends in
technology gives you something good I
think we're even able to do with with
silicon because the because
I think the effect that you're going to
get for saving running time on our neck
I'm calling in you know going in and out
of subroutines combined with with the
compactness that you get of having a
large number of registers in the program
is a win anyway I decided that this was
going to be the subroutine the
subroutine calling mechanism faith
recommended in my book soul or another
style of subroutine linkage can can also
be programmed with this with the other
with the other instruction it takes a
long time to explain these things and I
and and in this in this right up there
are some III also went into the the
things that are the messy details that
are needed all the instructions that are
needed by the operating system in order
to do its in order to for example get
things in and out of different caches
and the handle virtual virtual
addressing to to physical addressing and
what happens on interrupts and and how
do you restore confidence a non-save
context and things like that
there's mxs has 32 special registers
that are used each each has a number
from 0 to 31 and the and I told you
about the multiplex mask register for
example but there are other ways sort of
the high half of the product and things
like this so all those details are are
they're not not really needed for unless
you're going to write the operating
system and for some of the for some of
the weirder ones and I left a little bit
wondering about this easy to learn part
what if I have to look at the at the
entire document and say you're going to
learn all of the instructions that are
that are there in order to handle in
order to handle the the full
complexities of of operating system
but I I still needed those instructions
in order to make this thing complete and
I'm not going to end them and I'm going
to have those separated out into into
special reference books or not in in the
main text so in general I have to say
that I hope you all like it as much as I
do I can't wait till I own one of these
machines and I and I'm looking and I'm
actively looking for volunteers to help
with the job of translating all of the
programs that were done in in mixed into
ma for this purpose I've got a wonderful
help helper vladimir ivanovich that
bladder you hear a stand up please so
and he has just he is just setting up
the homepage for M McMasters which is
the which will be the volunteer group
and if this is w WM McMasters org and
and it is it's going to we're going to
they're going to be is going to help
organize so people will choose the parts
that they're going to work on and and
and all the information is here
furthermore in the next step in the next
few weeks I'm going to be making a lot
of decisions about the assembly language
that are and I would very much like to
to have a group of people that that we
would shoot the breeze about these ideas
for two or three hours and and and see
you know knock down my my my proposals
or for the member before I spend too
much time writing up something that
people aren't gonna like this is what we
did when when Tech was designed with uh
every Friday for about four years we we
had a meeting of two or three hours of
anybody could drop in and we a meal
you discuss the aspects of taken and I
hope I'm I'm looking forward for having
two or three meetings to talk about
ideas of a mix in in mark if any of you
are interested in participating in these
in these we could talk after after after
this right now and then after my lecture
in money in March on March 3rd and we'll
try to set times that work for people
because I I really would appreciate this
this chance for feedback on some of the
some of the trade-offs designing the the
assembly language the the hardwood the
architecture itself is fairly close to
is written is getting the point where
it's pretty much hard to change now but
right but I still not too late to make a
change if you've got a really really
great improvement on what I have okay
any questions not going to the home oh
no you think it's fair that good yeah
it would be a probably a good idea I
hadn't thought about that you know we
could yeah that's that's a good
suggestion because PI Motors is affected
right now by only the multiplied on sign
and so I could make it that I could make
it exactly equivalent and yeah I had
this idea that if they wouldn't have
just one or two auxiliary registers
having one only one or two or three
registers means there's a lot of
competition for them in the pipeline so
also a so you know so register that's
used for the upper half of
multiplication is different from the one
that's usefully upper half of a of a
dividend but here is the case where it's
quite natural for two instructions to
use the high multiple edges they're very
good yes
no no III birth tried that in the 60s
then I that's cool that's too radical
why would you prefer that I mean it yeah
I do that's true yeah that's true
in fact uh I even consider decimal
arithmetic you know I mean you know
computers are getting so fast now you
know that would you know if it might be
that you know tying them to make them
human friendly again but but I rejected
it I think Java should probably have
been decimal though I mean in its in its
applauding point but the biggest mistake
in tech was that I that I made it binary
I mean internally tech works in units of
two to the minus sixteen points and and
that and I should have had it be to that
end of the minus fifth point because
then the it be the thing that's printed
when it says how many points it is would
be exactly what what's inside the
computer right now it's a it's a rounded
approximation so so there's you know
there are aspects of of decimal
arithmetic that that that are better for
human not interaction but I guess what
binary computers are still here for
another ten years
anyway yeah now I should have mentioned
that this was done in the in the CRISPR
architecture The Hobbit and and that
right now my register stack when I push
things down it's only scalars that I can
push I can't address I can't address
registers that's but that's extremely
complicated in the pipeline so so I so I
rejected it at the moment but it's but
your point is well-taken
that that we use them in different ways
and and for example III have bank of
registers okay the the main the main
loss that I have like having this many
registers is that is that the immediate
instructor feels they're only eight bits
and Hannah seen Patterson gain
statistics of how how large in lots of
programs the immediate fields want it to
be and you could you could get I don't
know seventy five percent of all the
structure of all immediate would fit in
eight bits but then there were but you
could get up if you could get up to ten
bits then then you would hit ninety some
you know ninety-five ninety-six percent
of something of all instructions would
fit in a 10 bit immediate something like
that it was and and Here I am you know
with my with my nice one one byte for
each for each part of the word and
having only eight bits left for the what
for the immediate saw the base register
plus an 8 bit officer however I can
divide my base registers into groups of
four so let us actually have a 10 bit
offset because the lower two bits
identify which base register in the bank
before there are so if I have several
things that going off of one base
register I can actually have four eight
base registers grouped together based on
the on the context and that's another
example of how how in fact there is an
array of base registers and and here the
assembler will even allow you to carry
in so if you have the you know if you
wanted to have an immediate field that's
a little more than that's more than 8
bits it'll actually carry into the
number of the register but then they
loading routine will have set up those
registers to differ from each other by
256 yeah any of the operands for and or
horological immediate will have a lot of
leading ones well I have the negative
the negatives of these instructions too
and I have the wide instructions I have
there yeah yeah we can like we can talk
offline about this there but yeah
increments family the increment is
unsigned what do mediate is always
always a low byte except when I say a
medium-high immediate you know is that
the instructor like the set I had a sec
I said medium I said and those were
those were 16 bit immediate that's a
quick you know there's lots of quick
when you go to 64-bit a lot of problems
get harder than they were in the 32-bit
world because you could easily you could
more easily build a 32-bit constant than
you can say for bit but the most
significant problem on a 64-bit machine
was actually the ritual - - ritual of
address to physical address problem that
I have didn't get into because all all
the schemes that that are used on 32-bit
machines fail to scale up very well when
you when you have to when you when you
try to try to mean like the ideas of
page tables what which worked nicely
with 32-bit
I had to work very hard in order to have
something that would be reasonable I did
a way to do the mapping for all
conceivable changes in technology coming
up and I think I have a good compromise
but it's not simple it's hidden from
some essentially all users but still I
still that was perhaps the most
difficult 64-bit problem I faced
everything is aligned every every every
command is automatically aligned and
No if you do yes you can but it just
ignores the low three bids in fact those
low three bits are very valuable there's
a tremendous number of data structures
where you want a pointer plus one bit of
pointer plus two bits and so on and you
can use the law you can use the end of
the pointers can you got those bits
right there and it's totally ignored now
but I know that that the that there's
you know it was necessary for the Alpha
to have instructions that that allow
unaligned loads just because of a legacy
code but fortunately I don't have any
legacy code so so I can design the thing
to be right and and this multiply
instruction is this you know there's a
short routine we'll do the the the right
thing with unaligned load you and and
and then you do a couple of these more
instructions on it and it will shift the
bytes the way into the position that you
want and get it so it's a fairly short
loop to do to do on the line loads but
but I'm not going to but I'm saying that
the sensible program that starts out and
doesn't have to worry about legacy
everything is always aligned okay a max
inspection yes
the let's see it's it's well yeah it
needs two instructions but but you've
got the but you got to compare you've
got to compare and set it's less and so
you can subtract and then you do a
compare and set it less no no that's
that's the point and and there's also
maximum and minimum on on each byte
which you've been doing two instructions
you take the bike difference and then
you and then you do let's see and then
you add in
yeah yeah the the max is equal to the
max of X and y is equal to the the X -
white flush - 0 + y + it
that's the min and the max is similar
but you subtract so so Max and min on
individual bytes are there in 2
instructions as well okay well I guess
time is up and I'll be glad to answer
other questions